all right so we got back into that and
the it was getting kind of heated there
with the Pitbull prosecutor and Alec
Murdock and then they decided to take a
break which I can understand for
everybody
um but I imagine that the jury might
have just wanted to get this done today
judge but what's the strategy from the
judge just it's 5 30 we're going to call
it a day yeah I think that's a strategy
um and I I don't know the judge and I
don't know what the what he normally or
she I don't even know if the judge the
judge is a male I think uh I don't know
what the procedure is but you know even
when I was a judge the court officers
very often there was a union there would
be a union and the court officers would
have to be in there you know put their
guns away before X o'clock and that it
could be something that has nothing to
do with the trial per se but rather with
the unions who knows so then what is it
like tonight after this I'm assuming
he'll meet with his lawyers again yeah
yeah he'll meet with the lawyers
um now they they will talk to him
although so the jury will be advised not
to discuss this case with anyone with
each other not to read anything about it
not to listen to anything about it but
um they will tell him you know whether
or not they're going to go into any new
areas I doubt they're going to say too
much about the cross-examination they
shouldn't but they will be making a
decision also based upon the
cross-examination of this defendant as
to whether or not they're going to have
to go back with a rebuttal witness and
whether or not they're going to have to
bring anybody else out the prosecutor I
think is getting frustrated he's a pit
bull I think he's good but this guy
murder is a very cool cat he understands
every word that's being said he's smart
as hell and he's getting to one jury
sure I guarantee it by the way you know
it's an interesting thing just
observationally we couldn't do this in
England I wanted to ask you about that
we're not allowed to talk about cases
when they're wrong at all I mean other
than the journey you couldn't no no
newspaper no television show you
couldn't ask any comment during an
active trial well at all the idea that I
could sit here is just quite refreshing
I think I think it is the right thing
that America does where it's all very
transparent it's open well you can talk
you can move here
it's an interesting thing I mean if
you're in this jury this is a small town
right um to go home you can't talk about
it you might not even want to right you
might just want to watch reruns of
friends well that's definitely something
that someone at this table enjoys
just in this last couple hours or so did
you see one moment where that prosecutor
clearly drew blood on the stand no I'm
not sure if I'm a juror that there was
that one moment where I was like wow he
really got him or because as Janine said
he's calm and his pacing is perfect so
his pacing in terms of his answers his
Cadence is designed specifically
sometimes to run out the clock and to
frustrate the prosecutor and towards the
end it did look like the prosecutor was
being frustrated but look let me explain
something this is not over until it's
over all right that prosecutor you may
think he's losing but he's getting every
fact he needs for that closing argument
for the summation you know that this is
a guy who lied to a woman who's an
amputee and he said quadriplegic not
answering double amputee and so he can
look at you and lie to you as well so
everything that we find in this theater
of drama that we call a trial which is
what it is it's theater uh is not over
until they finish those those summations
and then the jury charges oh there's a
lot more to go in this I am being very
short-sighted and I would agree with
that so it's not over to the enormous
person sings Yeah
I fixed it yes yes yes thank you well
then can I ask you something then judge
because what I am curious about who else
they would call at this point is this
isn't it almost done
uh I would think so but I haven't
followed it that closely maybe the
prosecutor you know although it may not
be material to the case may want to
bring back a quadriplegic to say you
know he kind of didn't admit he said you
know I sold money my partner wasn't
involved in it but I don't remember that
conversation and so they'd have to go
before the judge the D.A and say I want
to bring in the quadriplegic they've
specifically had that conversation the
judge will say well that's not really
material it's whether he killed his wife
and son yeah just at the end don't you
just stand there and play the jury the
WhatsApp video
this guy said he was nowhere near the
scene of this crime he's appalled he's
horrified he made the call later and
then there's a WhatsApp video and he's
in it he admitted he lied right but he's
any he's there when this happens it
happens literally like four or five
minutes later doesn't it so what's
happened he suddenly disappears and then
they get killed it's nonsense and if I'm
a juror I'm like yeah he's a nice guy
and he's saying all the right things but
ultimately yeah hang on he was there
right right I mean he's there yeah
incontrovertibly it's it's like the old
it's the opposite of the O.J Simpson
glove this is like if you believe the
vid then you believe the dead maybe I'll
have to say that
but I do I just think it's
incontrovertible to me that once he'd
lied about that he didn't want people to
think he was anywhere near it when it
happened and then it turns out here's
the video he's there one thing that he
did on by taking the stand was he
planted a seed and it did in addition to
creating the premise for making sure
that they down charge he planted a seed
that someone else did it he said Paul
had gotten threats unbelievable threats
after the boat crash and that case was
coming to trial right away so you know
there may be another person who'd done
it I don't believe it but no no I agree
with you I think he's a very skillful
operator in defending himself and his
decision to go on the stand clearly was
the right one because we're all agreed
he's putting on a good performance I
just think it's all a complete load of
phooey as we would say yeah well I'd use
a different word but uh judge if you
were the prosecutor in this in this case
do you like the way the judge hit the
recess button do you right now did it
favor who did it favor the way it was
stopped would you be happy with that
stuff I think I think it favors the
prosecution because they can go back and
look at what they've done and look at
what they need to do tomorrow wrap it up
you want to end with the prosecutor
because they're sleeping on the last
thing they heard you don't want to end
with a defense
interesting hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now